[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg
Samstagabend willkommen zum
Nachrichtenüberblick Norbert König ist
auch dabei für den Sport sehr gern guten
Abend und das sind unsere Themen von
heute
Debatte um Asylbewerber Forderungen nach
einer Umstellung auf Sachleistungen und
einer schnelleren Arbeitserlaubnis
werden lauter
[Musik]
zu entvölkert etwa 100.000 Menschen
haben die Region nach den Kämpfen
inzwischen verlassen
und Opa mit Kind und Kegel auf der Suche
nach dem Konzerthaus der Zukunft geht
Frankfurt neue Wege
[Musik]
viele Städte
ächzen unter der wachsenden Zahl
ankommende Asylbewerber selbst der
Bundeskanzler sagt es seien zu viele die
nach Deutschland Streben nur was tun
schärfere Kontrollen an den Grenzen nur
noch Sachleistungen statt Bargeld für
Asylbewerber Flüchtlingen direkt nach
Ihrer Ankunft des Arbeiten erlauben
Andrea Maurer über die Debatte
in der Debatte um den Umgang mit
Asylbewerbern hat sich die
bundesinnenministerin bei einem
Wahlkampftermin in Hessen hinter die
Forderung gestellt geflüchtete schneller
in Arbeit zu bringen zumal wir alle
Integrationskurse ab dem ersten Tag
geöffnet hat dass jemand hier ist
unabhängig von der Bleibeperspektive
weil wir für wichtig halten dass man vom
ersten Tag an Integrationsmaßnahmen
eröffnet auch Grüne und FDP sind für
eine beschleunigte Arbeitsaufnahme
Uneinigkeit dagegen bei der Debatte um
Geldleistung weil sie ein Zitat Anreiz
zur Einreise in die Sozialsysteme sein
will FDP digitalminister Wissing
Geldleistung durch Bezahlkarten ersetzen
mit den geflüchtete ihren täglichen
Bedarf im Einzelhandel decken können die
migrationsbeauftragte hat Einwände die
Bundesländer können bereits
Sachleistungen oder auch Bezahlkarten
ausgeben das machen die wenigsten
Bundesländer das ist doch vom
bürokratischen Aufwand sehr groß ob
Sachleistungen jetzt wirklich der Weg
sind um die Menschen abzuschrecken da
bin ich eher kritisch
der Kanzler setzt nun darauf illegale
Zuwanderung mit schärferen
Grenzkontrollen einzudämmen die Zahl der
Flüchtlinge die nach Deutschland Streben
ist im Moment zu hoch sagte er in einem
Interview und spricht sich in der Frage
wie Kommunen entlastet werden können
auch für pauschalen pro Flüchtling aus
die die Länder für Unterbringung
Versorgung und Integration schon lange
fordern im November ist migrationsgipfel
im Kanzleramt die Union hat den Kanzler
schon vorher um ein migrationsgespräch
gebeten nach den Landtagswahlen in einer
Woche
in Berlin zwingt die wachsende Zahl von
ankommenden die Regierung zum Handeln
also ganz offensichtlich verwandelt sich
die steigende Zahl der ankommenden in
steigenden politischen Handlungsdruck
denn die Zahl der Flüchtlinge ist ja
gleichbedeutend mit Überforderung in
vielen Kommunen mit kritischer Stimmung
mit lauten Forderungen der Opposition
und nicht zu vergessen in acht Tagen
sind zwei wichtige Landtagswahlen und
daher kommen jetzt gleich aus allen
Regierungsparteien Handlungsempfehlungen
sei es der sofortige oder zumindest
schnellere Zugang zum Arbeitsmarkt sei
es die Verhinderung von Barzahlung zur
Vermeidung von Rücküberweisung in die
Heimatländer wenn der Kanzler heute sagt
die Zahl der Flüchtlinge sei momentan zu
hoch dann ist es jedenfalls ein anderes
Signal als ein wir schaffen das die
politischen Spielräume der Ampel
scheinen mehr enger gezogen zu werden
gerade erst hat die Baukrise ja zwei
klimavorhaben beiseite geschoben und
jetzt gibt es auffällige Bewegungen beim
Thema Asyl
vielen Dank für diese Einschätzung aus
Berlin danke schön
nach seinen Äußerungen über Zahnarzt
Behandlungen für abgelehnte Asylbewerber
wird CDU-Chef Merz auch aus den eigenen
rein kritisiert vom CDU sozialflügel
dessen Vizechef Christian Bäumler
forderte März auf seine Äußerungen
zurückzunehmen oder auf die
Kanzlerkandidatur zu verzichten die
Entgleisungen von März sei nicht mit dem
christlichen Menschenbild vereinbar so
Bäumler viele CDU-Mitglieder schenken
sich für ihren Parteivorsitzende
blicken wir nach Berg Karabach 10 Tage
nach der Militäroffensive Aserbaidschans
ist der Großteil der Armenier aus der
Region geflohen laut Regierung kam
mittlerweile mehr als 100.000
Flüchtlinge aus berkarabach in Armenien
an vor der Massenflucht lebten in der
Region etwa 120.000 Armenia wie die
Situation an der Grenze aussieht dazu
Nina Niebergall
Sam will haben wir zu mirn hat immerhin
überlebt er wurde bei einer schweren
Explosion an einer Tankstelle in
Bergkarabach verletzt Brandwunden mit
denen er dann auch noch fliehen musste
erstmal in die armenische Grenzstadt
gohres
mir geht es okay ich bin nur froh dass
wir hier in Gores so viel Hilfe bekommen
die Armenia aus bergkarre Bach kommen
inzwischen Busse Weise reden wollen
viele nicht zu traumatisch die Flucht
die sie hier Vertreibungen nennen die
armenische rot-kreuz-gesellschaft hilft
sogar Jugendliche packen mit an
koordiniert von ayapi
niemand sollte auf der Straße schlafen
müssen
internationale Unterstützung kam spät
die Organisation ärzte der Welt ist erst
seit zwei Tagen hier versucht die
Menschen vor allem mental zu
unterstützen sie fühlen sich von allen
im Stich gelassen
und das macht es besonders schwierig
weil sie eigentlich
ja sie sind
sie wissen gar nicht jetzt wie von wem
und wie es weitergehen soll sondern das
ist einfach nur leere manche haben
Familie in Armenien und sind froh
erstmal sicher zu sein
genau vor einem Jahr hat der russische
Präsident Putin mehrere ukrainische
Gebiete zu Teilen Russlands erklärt nach
dem Einmarsch hatten die Russen die
Regionen
saporicia donetz und Johannes
völkerrechtswidrig annektiert
kontrollieren sie aber nur teilweise wie
pompös Moskau den Jahrestag inszeniert
zeigt Armin Körper
Mein Kampf heißt dieses lied
der Sänger schaman ist das Pop-Sternchen
der Propaganda so inszeniert Russland
auf dem Roten Platz von Moskau den
Jahrestag einer völkerrechtswidrigen
Annexion vor Kreml treuen aus dem ganzen
Land es geht um den Beitritt von uralten
russischen Territorien wir sind sehr
stolz heute vor einem Jahr die
Stadthalter der noch immer nicht
vollständig eroberten Regionen in der
Ukraine treten Russland bei Präsident
Putin heute mit bekannten Parolen nichts
und niemand kann den Willen von
Millionen Menschen brechen ihren Glauben
an Wahrheit und historische
Gerechtigkeit denn Freien und
unmissverständlichen Ruf unserer Brüder
und Schwestern den das russische Volk
von ganzem Herzen unterstützt im
russisch besetzten Mario Paul hatten sie
sich Monate lang gegen die Besatzer
gewehrt vergeben heute können sie nicht
frei sprechen doch nach Feierlaune
klingt es wahrlich nicht
wir haben alles verloren unsere lieben
unsere Häuser besser geht's uns jetzt
sicher nicht
zurück nach Moskau Finale mit Hymne
es ist eine perfekte propaganda-show die
die da nicht mitsingen wollen sind heute
in Russland auf keiner Bühne zu sehen
[Musik]
man kann nur ahnen was diese Bilder in
der Ukraine auslösen seit mehr als
eineinhalb Jahren versuchen die Menschen
dort den Krieg zu überleben und hoffen
dass nicht vergessen wird welche
Grausamkeiten die russischen Besatzer
ihnen antun und angetan haben zum
Beispiel in Issum eine Brühl war dort
Tod und Zerstörung noch immer sind sie
allgegenwärtiginesen auch im ehemaligen
Polizeipräsidium dem Arbeitsplatz von
yakif palamatschuk als die Russen den
Ort zu Beginn des Kriegs besetzten wurde
das hier ein Folterkeller
militärleute auch Zivilisten alle die
ihnen nicht gefielen wurden hierher
gebracht
nach drei Monaten wird auch palamatschuk
abgeholt gefesselt und mit einem Sack
über dem Kopf in eine der Garagen auf
dem Gelände gebracht
ich dachte dass ich sterbe denn sie
haben angefangen den bolzener
Maschinengewehr zu ziehen sie haben mir
gedroht
der
kiefernwaldhafter Ort
449 Leichen hat man nach dem Abzug der
Russen in Massengräbern gefunden viele
zeigten Anzeichen eines gewaltsamen
Todes die Polizei untersucht jeden
einzelnen Fall
es ist sehr wichtig für die Leute hier
in die Zoom denn das sind ihre nächsten
ihre Nachbarn ihre Bekannten
48 Leichen sind noch immer nicht
identifiziert Sorgfalt geht vor
Schnelligkeit
wir dokumentieren alles damit Russland
bestraft wird ich glaube daran an das
Gericht in Den Haag
hoffen auf Gerechtigkeit vor dem
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof und
darauf dass isum nicht noch einmal von
russischen Truppen besetzt wird
angesichts wachsender Spannungen
zwischen Serbien und dem Kosovo haben
die USA die serbische Seite zur
sofortigen Deeskalation aufgefordert die
US-Regierung spricht von einem
beispiellosen Aufgebot von serbischer
Artillerie und Panzern an der Grenze zum
Kosovo auch Deutschland warnt vor
weiterer Eskalation der Kosovo hatte
sich 2008 für unabhängig erklärt Serbien
erkennt das nicht an
die Demokratie lebt davon dass Bürger zu
ihr stehen und sie verteidigen das sagt
Niedersachsens Ministerpräsident weil
auf einer Protestveranstaltung in
Eschede heute seit Jahren wären sich in
Eschede Bürger gegen Neonazis die sich
in der Nähe zu Sonnenwendfeiern und
ernted versammeln auch heute wieder mal
in Urlaub berichtet
ein breites Bündnis hatte aufgerufen
Gewerkschaften kirchenparteien und
Bürger protestieren im niedersächsischen
Eschede gegen ein Treffen von Neonazis
in der Lüneburger Heide Anlass für das
Treffen der Rechtsextremisten ist ein
sogenanntes Erntedankfest beim
Gegenprotest dabei auch Niedersachsens
Ministerpräsident Stefan weil ich finde
es wichtig dass man deutlich macht dass
die Demokraten
Rechtsextremismus nicht tatenlos
hinnehmen sondern dass man darauf
hinweist und dass man dagegen heute zum
Beispiel auch demonstriert wir erleben
ja das Rechtsextremismus denken doch in
unserer Gesellschaft in größeren Teilen
Einzug hält bereits seit fast drei
Jahrzehnten finden auf dem früheren Hof
des npd-aktivisten Joachim NAZ große
Neonazi Treffen statt besonders die
Sonnenwendfeiern und die Erntedankfeste
haben hier lange Traditionen aber sie
sind keine harmlosen treffen sie dienen
der Vernetzung der norddeutschen
Neonazi-Szene
sie behaupten dass wir ein
brauchtumsfeiern einfach um braucht um
zu pflegen aber wir wissen genau dass
sie hier auch zusammenkommen um sich
abzusprechen um Aktionen zu schmieden
und das wollen wir einfach nicht
zulassen
mehrere hundert haben hier demonstriert
gegen Rechtsextremismus die Bevölkerung
hat eine ganz klare Haltung dass sie das
hier nicht will sie sieht auch diese
Bedrohungslage
zeigt Haltung sie wollen Zeichen setzen
gegen einen rechtsextremes treffen auf
einem Privatgelände gegen das ist kaum
eine rechtliche Handhabe gibt
an der Raststätte Gräfenhausen bei
Darmstadt haben die Streikenden
Lastwagenfahrer ihren Protest beendet
seit Mitte Juli stand hier alles still
bis zu 120 meist usbekische und
georgische Lkw-Fahrer streikten weil
eine polnische Spedition ihre Löhne
nicht zahlte nun die Einigung nach
Gewerkschaftsangaben bekommen die Fahrer
ihr Geld bereits erstattete Anzeigen
gegen sie werden zurückgezogen
die Alte Oper in Frankfurt am Main sie
geht gerade völlig neue Wege mit gratis
Konzerten für allen Klassik Jazz oder
auch wilde Tanzabende mit DJ täglich ab
14:30 Uhr ist das Konzerthaus geöffnet
fratopia heißt das Festival die Resonanz
ist gewaltig Andrea Mäuser mit einer
Bilanz
keine Reservierung kein Eintrittspreis
einfach nur kommen und zuhören 5 Tage
und 80 Konzerte mit klassischer Musik
im Großen und im kleinen Rahmen
jungen Entdeckungen und großen Namen
viele lockte das zum ersten Mal in die
Alte Oper ich habe es auf Instagram
gesehen und man wollte immer schon mal
in die Oper gehen und das ist anders und
dann der Freundin dabei einmal erster
Eindruck zu gewinnen die Abendprogramme
die man hier sonst findet die ziehen
sich lange meistens und das richtet sich
dann nicht an das jüngere Publikum
war konnte sehen die altbewährte Form
Künstler auf der Bühne Publikum ganz
weit weg die muss nicht sein auf dem
Boden im Stehen oder im Liegen jeder und
jede sollte lauschen wie es ihm und ihr
gefällt wir wollen die Menschen
begeistern
wir wollen erproben wie es aussehen
könnte das Konzerthaus der Zukunft und
dieses Konzerthaus der Zukunft das ist
lebendig das ist durchlässig das ist
offen und die Künstler auch sie erlebten
neues mit dem neuen Format
die Atmosphäre sehr intim und sehr
intensiv und das macht total viel Spaß
und gibt ganz viel Energie nächstes Jahr
soll diese Energie wieder zu spüren sein
die Alte Oper Frankfurt plant frautopia
auch für 2024
ja ganz viel Energie auch bei der
Fußball-Bundesliga der Frauen haben die
hoffenheimerinnen ein Superstar erwischt
ja absolut mit einem 19:0 gegen Duisburg
sind sie vor zwei Wochen in die Saison
eingestiegen und lassen heute am zweiten
Spieltag ein 3:1 bei Werder Bremen
folgen die TSG Hoffenheim seit zehn
Jahren im Frauenfußball erstklassig
grüßt zumindest vorläufig von der
Tabellenspitze
weder die Bremerinnen in den Grün-Weißen
Trikots noch die Gäste aus Hoffenheim
hätten geglaubt dass sie laut Tabelle
der Spitzenspiel austragen schon nach 13
Minuten gehen die hoffenheimerinnen
durch Melissa Köster in Führung mit
ihrem bereits 14
Minuten nach der Pause gibt es einen
berechtigten Elfmeter für Hoffenheim den
allerdings Nicole Bieler in die Arme von
Bremen ins Torhüterin Livia Penis
schießt auf der Gegenseite kann
martinavic einen eigentlich unhaltbaren
Schuss parieren sie dann aber nach der
anschließenden Ecke nicht gut aus und
muss den allgemeinen Getümmel nach 71
Minuten den Bremer Ausgleich durch
Michelle Ulbricht zulassen
doch nur drei Minuten später stellt Mara
Alba mit dem 2:1 die Hoffenheimer
Führung wieder her gegen auf den
Ausgleich drängende Bremerinnen erzählt
die Belgierin Janssens den drei zu eins
entstand Bremen wird wohl auch in diesem
Jahr gegen den Abstieg spielen während
sich die TSG Hoffenheim vorgenommen hat
zum Kreis der Teams an der erweiterten
Tabellenspitze zu gehören
bei den Männern jubeln die Leverkusener
Profis über den vorläufigen Sprung an
die Tabellenspitze durch den fünften
Sieg im sechsten Saisonspiel der
Bundesliga gleichzeitig ist das die 5
Niederlage für Mainz 0:3 5 Erfolg
dagegen auch für Stuttgart 2:0 in Köln
Bochum gegen Gladbach 1:3 Heidenheims
zweiter Sieg 1:0 gegen Union Berlin
Wolfsburg beschert Frankfurt mit 2:0 die
erste Niederlage ausführlich im
Sportstudio das Topspiel Leipzig gegen
München gestern Hoffenheim Dortmund
1:32 Spiele morgen nur mit einem Sieg
können sich die Bayern die
Tabellenführung von Leverkusen
zurückholen Stuttgarter Bären stark
Dortmund nach drei Erfolgen wieder oben
dabei Heidenheim bis morgen sogar in der
oberen Hälfte unten sind die letzten
vier Mannschaften noch sieglos
Aufsteiger Darmstadt kann das Ändern
morgen Nachmittag gegen Bremen Mainzer
Leverkusens Geschäftsführer Simon Rolfes
wird dagegen heute abend best gelaunt
ins aktuelle Sportstudio kommen 23 Uhr
geht's los Dankeschön bitteschön und wir
haben zum Schluss noch einen Blick nach
Las Vegas gestern Abend Weltpremiere und
zwar dieser
konzertkugel es ist nach Angaben der
Betreiber die größte kugelförmige Halle
der Welt ein gigantischer LED-Bildschirm
die Außenwand umgerechnet 8
Fußballfelder groß als erstes darf die
irische Band Youtube das ganze bespielen
geplant sind 25 Konzerte alle
ausverkauft
485 € für das günstigste Ticket zu hören
unter anderem Rock Hymnen Wiese
[Musik]
das Herbstwetter ist weiter sehr
sommerlich mehr dazu hat gleich essen
Sievers meldet sich um 11:15 Uhr mit dem
heute journal alles Gute Ihnen einen
schönen Samstagabend und bis morgen wenn
Sie mögen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ja nach diesem
Rekord September der ja der wärmste seit
Aufzeichnungsbeginn war geht es jetzt im
Oktober ab morgen auch warm weiter das
liegt daran an diesem Hoch hier das
warme Luft mitbringt und das Gerät eben
auch in Hochdruck Einfluss und dann
erwärmt sich die Luft noch weiter so
sind 30 Grad am Montag durchaus drin in
der Nacht gibt es etwas Regen im
Nordwesten ansonsten kompaktere Wolken
im Osten im Süden Nebel dazwischen
funkeln auch mal die Sterne bei tiefsten
Temperaturen dort bis 5 Grad also hier
schon recht kalt 15 Grad an der Nordsee
morgen dort im Nordsee Umfeld und nach
Osten in Wolken die durchziehen und
Regen bringen auch Richtung Binnenlands
ganz im Süden sonniges Wetter an der
Donau kann sich der Nebel etwas länger
halten wenn er sich auflöst gibt's viel
Sonnenschein Temperaturen bis 26 Grad
hier also locker ein Sommertag und 17°c
zum Beispiel an der Ostsee die nächsten
Tage am Montag bis 30 Grad möglich im
Norden Regen sonst aber viel
Sonnenschein ja am Dienstag weiter Regen
im Norden und dazu auch eine Kaltfront
die uns zu erreichen bis 27 Grad ein
schönen Abend